almost anything that could be kicked
over broken
was destroyed this was all boarded up
i'm true to what i do new york bounces
back like it always has
it's really nice to see life coming back
to the neighborhood they don't want to
know
here's the residual effect of the riots
absolutely
somehow becomes the inspiration for so
many people it seems to
have a soul millions three floors almost
right especially for a new yorker and i
can't do
me because i'm trying to get something
[Music]
new york city coveted times today we're
going to meet with a local named frank
and frank has lived and worked in new
york city
the majority of his life and frank's
going to show us
the dramatic changes that have been
taking place
in the city since the start of the
[Music]
pandemic
frank how you doing good bro
thank you sorry to get you up so early
no it's nice
normal saturday morning this is packed
packed and
during the week this would be this is
impossible there'd be lines of cars
there'd be
cabs three blocks deep and excellent
because you're the creature of now and
your birthday is coming up with boots
around the corner
mine's already here i made 63 and i'm
trying to do a little forgery
because i'm trying
this is my brother you're not from texas
you're from the land of wise
i mean take that but let me have that
because
just in case somebody gets stupid and
youtube now you wouldn't think this is
staged
because i'm five alive with you
take care man what's your name my name
is red towns and katie son
i'm from 112th street st nicholas and
i'm a man 63 i've made myself through
i'm true to what i do yeah you are yeah
i see a job
too
i like that guy so that's what's great
about new york right that's what's great
about new york
that's the new york theme you know as
you get to be yourself here
what's your backstory what's your
history with the city i came into
construction i had a scholarship to
pratt institute for art and a professor
said
hey frank you want to go through life
painting naked women
and i was like sure you know he said
great then you'll be a starving artist
so what he found interesting was that i
i drew architecture
okay and so uh he suggested that maybe i
take it
to that direction and it didn't and it
and worked for me so
so i've been here working since uh 1979
and it's sad to me that in the last
eight months or so this has changed
just turned on a dime just you
can't even believe that that could
happen on its own so how how what are
the big changes
well i'm going to show you i'm going to
show you some things
we walk down 8th avenue you will
actually see
boarded up buildings uh mainline stores
dwayne reed
stores uh anchor stores that are gone
and this is a busy street this is this
is the main street between
penn station and port authority so
what's happened with these just a few
weeks ago well actually you can see the
residual
graffiti that was on the boards right
this has turned the corner it looks much
much cleaner
this um six weeks ago was almost
frightening
especially for a new yorker to walk down
this area
yeah and we're walking towards the east
village we're what october 3rd right now
october 3rd that's correct what's uh do
you feel like the city's
versus a month ago is is more lively is
coming back
no i don't think it's coming back and
the way i judge that
is if you're uh if you go out to jersey
yeah and you go into some of these
suburban areas where there are parking
lots for mass transportation trains
buses yeah
the parking lots are ten percent full
yep today
we came over on the ferry there were
like ten people on it that's
300 people trying to imagine so these
are barricades
okay police station up this street
normally this is closed off now you
would see police officers here
this would be a no through traffic area
so they're starting to lighten this up a
little bit
and you can still see the barricades
here yep
and you can look up the street and you
can see some police cars
and that's new york new york is
everyone's private
everyone's deliberate they have their
own little cause
well as an outsider i've never lived
here i find it very friendly honestly
if i go up and talk to people people are
usually cool they want to talk
yeah i'd agree with you it's the general
demeanor of new york
it's an island yes everyone's doing
their own thing yes
but i feel like it's also a place
you can get some real conversation
pretty easily you can
almost anything that could be kicked
over broken was destroyed
and this is about where it ended this is
we're coming into the east village at
this point
this becomes a pretty affluent area now
it changed there was
minor destruction from this point on and
it's funny how that happens
it just sort of stopped huh right and
was there more of a police presence or
something or
no there's more of um
it's it's almost like this is carved out
on a map and said okay here's the area
we want you to protest it because it
does stop
right here who do you think is carving
that out
believe what you want again it goes back
to
you know political influences yeah i
honestly feel like i can't put a finger
on it exactly but i honestly feel like
we're getting played as a society right
now
i'd agree with fully played because when
i was watching america from abroad
like i said i've lived in ukraine the
last four years i'm watching it from
abroad
scratching my head a bit and when i'm on
the streets
i don't know yeah i think everyone seems
to i don't i don't have any problems
i think there's mixed opinions now uh
beyond the us uh i think those
there's still people wanting to come
here
oh yeah because even with our troubles
yeah
there's still nothing like america look
i am more appreciative of the states
right now at the age of 43 than i've
ever been in my life
ever yeah and i was always you know
grass is greener
on the other side i've seen a lot of the
world i've gained a lot from being in
other parts of the world and i
appreciate those experiences but
coming back this time and i see through
my wife's eyes who's ukrainian
she points out things to me that i would
never see there's a great openness here
and you can see it physically meaning to
walk into some like luxury building like
we did last
night as strangers and sure
people are open some are close but
compared to most of the world
you can really crack into people easier
here i find
it's always been that's always been the
culture yeah i love it
i think it's i think it's the beauty of
the culture where are we now frank
this is uh east village okay so they get
to the east village this is getting very
wealthy right
yes this this is a very affluent area
how much for one of these places
millions millions for uh little brown
stuff
the three floors yeah okay we can call
up that one's for sale
maybe you'll have an interest in moving
here i mean the the boarded up buildings
right block away it stops and look where
you are
this doesn't even look like new york
city so why wouldn't the
why wouldn't the protests come through
here you think you'd create more noise
you know what i mean
with people if you came through a
neighborhood like this you would think i
saw a small
black lives matter's protest here
uh it was somewhat civil you know they
harassed a few people
but not physically just you know
verbally harassed a few people then they
moved on
but there just doesn't seem to be any
trouble right here
okay and as the for the covet issue you
can see the little restaurants all have
setups outside
right so they won't be permitted to do
that
who lives here in this neighborhood
primarily i'm sure all types but
all types uh everyone from entertainers
bankers
any any uh politicians earning
people will look at yes can politicians
afford to live here
uh that's a good question that's like a
loaded question
sure uh most politicians become very
wealthy
ironically in a very short time
and and certainly this is where they
would live
okay new york's a living breathing place
uh and it somehow becomes the
inspiration for so many people
in arts in finance uh
it it just doesn't matter it it it seems
to
have a soul of its own and when you come
here you feel it
you you said it yourself you you find
that people want to talk
that's that's kind of unusual isn't it
everybody seems to
be connected to this energy that this
island
produces it can bring out your best
would you say that
it would definitely bring out your best
it would definitely encourage you
to do more there's something about the
lifestyle and the look of the area
that's something
it really does it resonates with some
part of your soul
that tells you drive forward do more
express yourself develop you develop
your abilities your talents whatever
they are
it this this place doesn't discriminate
new york city itself does not allow you
to be insecure it encourages you to be
yourself so even in these times you
don't feel like that's going away at all
no now new york is still is still new
york city you'll never change
you'll never change that politicians
have
seemed to degrade
the integrity of this city and i don't
know why i don't i don't know what the
hope is
but uh yeah what's the reasoning behind
that
i don't know i guess it's part of that
uh political discussion we had earlier
where uh it's a it's a movement to
weaken this this culture and the society
and perhaps flip it to a socialist
mentality i can only think that
i don't have any proof of that but
that's what i think
you know what i like is everyone's very
expressive here nobody's
and that's part of what i just said
nobody's really humble
everyone's yelling on the streets you
know about their personal
problems or whatever you live in the
neighborhood
how are you doing how are things right
now great
it's really nice to see life coming back
to the neighborhood oh it's coming back
i was here all along gotcha and you know
there were a couple of scary nights with
the uh looting
and then it was just so empty because so
many people
left this is the fairly accurate
neighborhood
so it seemed to me like 70 of the people
were missing for a while
but now they're all coming back and all
this so glad to be back in new york city
and the kids are back
restaurants are serving you know it
really helps to be optimistic yeah
pointed out there's been a significant
change in a few weeks right
oh yes enormous change it's clean again
yeah i got a bad shot for that but
they'll get taken out later today yeah
but uh
but in general it's clean right yeah uh
not six weeks ago
so this was all trashed up six weeks ago
this garbage would have just been all
over the streets
ah so how did you feel as a resident
seeing that six weeks ago
perhaps yeah how did you feel as a
resident seeing that happen
to your neighborhood oh well it was very
depressing
of course but you know
one thing about new york is we really do
have this wall in it together
okay feeling yep and it really does help
us get through things
oh my gosh in 65 i was 17
holy i mean yeah that is
right that's crazy i mean you've seen it
all
building i live in jimi hendrix lived in
whoa yeah
you're in the village he lived there
when he died he died on the road he
didn't find him
and it was a rental building so a couple
months later the city of brunswick came
with all this stuff on the street oh my
gosh
that's grabbing guitars and everything
he could and putting them in the
basement
and then a couple months later his
family came and took them all the way oh
i'll just say it's what that's worth
today i know
so would you ever leave the city no
where would i go see i told you she's
got a connection
to the city's soul the city lives and
breathes
and it and you just become part of that
and it's it's it's really not even
explainable
you feel that the soul here oh
absolutely quicker
it's like the beatles abbey road
so freedom tower way back
uh hopefully not that much bigger than
he is right now oh that's cool parker
boy do you live in the neighborhood i do
i love cover blocks over there oh cool
how's it been lately
um it's been good and that's what we're
talking about we're talking about the
city has a soul
exactly like heels
no not the trash parker yeah it does
like the
it's still like it still feels like new
york like even if people say
that it's not right absolutely
a place that will take you back to your
natural
born gifts so uh
so i like to write i write dark poetry
i write stories and uh
so there are areas that are captivating
you may walk down the street and find a
little park
and sit there and in that moment
there's the light of inspiration it hits
you
and you get your phone out you go into
notes and you start writing whatever
comes to you
that's new york new york does that it
has a soul it's a spirit
that connects to you it's an exceptional
place
and every culture every ethnicity every
religion
every political physician it lives here
it's a very diverse place and if you're
open-minded
it's enlightening certainly it is
are you always learning always i read
other people's work
and i try not to let it influence mine
but you know you never think your work
is good enough so when i write
yeah i think i'm writing okay and you
get that little writer's block now and
then but then you pick up something and
you read
and you just can't believe that someone
else can
formulate such a thought and put it on
paper
so eloquently and uh it makes you go i'm
gonna do better i'm i'm
gonna try to to uh
to define my voice i wanna i wanna i
wanted to be defined like
they are so this is a uh a column that's
existed from
earlier 1800s so i think so is this
girder
and then this space is pretty much built
around
the pre-existing brick and mortar
beautiful space
these curved windows here coming back
now to penn station
and here we are at 30th street and again
here's the residual
effect of of the riots there's still a
street that's closed off
for this precinct and yet you have to
ask yourself why they close off the
street still to today
right it's closed off because there's a
threat
there's no homeless you can see it
laying on the streets only past one or
two here and there
but six weeks ago there may have been
thirty where that where'd they go
don't know i don't know where they came
from huh because there was never that
many
and uh we're in great economic times uh
prior to coven right then we have the
highest level of employment
yeah how was it then were there very few
homeless or you know
you know or it's hard to tell when there
are more people in the city it's very
hard to tell
you can't just tell somebody to get up
and go to work with a heroin addict
right you know what you have to do is
get them
clean somehow or find out what the
psychological issues are
yeah so do they deserve help yeah
i would agree that's where i would agree
that that's where it needed help
this was all boarded up
so it changes quickly you're saying the
only thing that can
change that quickly
is politics how do you swing this from
absolute destruction
to prosperity again wait wait isn't
politics usually slow wouldn't you say
government's slow at things
only what it wants to be slow with okay
so here when you were in a an election
year and you've chased out your own
supporters
in fear what's left
you got to clean up the place and bring
them back so the city's got to be losing
an insane amount of money every day
tremendous amounts
you know people who own real estate are
losing money you know they have uh
commitments to banks right the mortgages
loans
and you have a building that's only half
rented
you know how do you how do you pay your
mortgage
to walk out here so art comes from the
soul
and we don't know what part of
spirituality art is connected to
so in my case i would see things and
draw them
and an art teacher pointed out that he
had
come to see a picture that i had drawn
at 13 years old
and then a month later he picked up a
newspaper and saw virtually
the same picture here hold on one second
so and i asked him this your mom passed
and he said yeah she is i said well
so if you can see your mom
are you remembering her or is she with
you or is it just your imagination
which he didn't have an answer for so i
said well
so for me perhaps and i'll describe your
mom
perhaps i'm seeing her because i'm
connecting to some part of your memory
or maybe i'm seeing her or maybe it's
just my imagination and i
have an accurate imagination
but how would you know and he had no
answer
so art and vision
can be inspired by a spiritual
connection
there's some force inside of you that
helps you create for some significant
reason you're creating a film
right now there's something driving you
to do this right
right so is it some vision you have in
your head
is there something that motivates you
what's inspiring you
to have a voice that people can hear so
it's the same thing are you driven
spiritually you know
and these are the questions that people
don't often ask themselves
they don't want to know they don't want
to know if they're in touch with a
higher spirit or their simple
imaginations
i don't think people give themselves
enough credit but we're so
so taxed with anger and and
culture the culture we created here that
i asked the question
who would you be had you ever had the
opportunity to be yourself
and you won't ever know that because
you're right here in new york city
some people in new york city come here
just for that
they come here to feel this connection
to open themselves up and allow
themselves to be who they want to be
who they thought they would be and there
are others who just
come here to observe it
[Music]
interesting right so
i i suggest to anybody to open up your
minds
open up your heart open up your soul be
who you want to be we have a certain
level of conformity we have to follow
that's a societal rule but you do get to
be who you want to be
for me i'll express my art my literature
even the passion by which i sing it's
mine
good or bad can we hear your voice we
can't
but but uh
the point is like i said good or bad
it's what i am acceptable or not
likeable or not it's just who i am
beautiful look at this weed
the weed rv check that out weed world
candies
there you go it used to be illegal now
it's
look at the area we're in now yeah and
you see it becoming more of a business
area
this tall one yeah that was a project
that i was on for a while
you were on it what do you mean by that
uh we were
well tishman actually is building the
entire building
and uh fishman interior is doing some of
the floors on the inside it was stopped
for a short time
uh during the height of covid
and uh then the permits were restored we
were on site most of the time
it was under construction so we were
considered essential
okay and had to uh come into new york
city
to be on that job so you worked during
covet pretty much the whole
pretty much the whole time yeah what was
the city like
at that time down here no none of this
right
you know it was eerie there was this
ominous feeling of dread
no people walking around there was uh
a terrible terrible moment in new york
city you know what they say the city
that never sleeps
and yet here we are with
virtually no ones no one in this park
one of the most famous parks in new york
and uh was empty and you know we risked
our lives in that sense that we didn't
really understand
covid we didn't know how severe it was
either we tried to protect
ourselves we wore gloves we wore masks
and it was a bad time let's check this
out okay so moving forward though with
new york
how will it how will it break out it
looks a capitalist
culture in that and some of the biggest
businesses are right here in new york
right everything that's relative to
investment
banking uh real estate
it's all right here in new york right
right so
it's one of the biggest capitalist
countries in the world
the city itself is like a capitalist
country if you can make it here
you can make it anywhere right that was
the theme cause we're talking about
you having the free opportunity to
exercise
your right to be an entrepreneur yeah
and come here and develop
whatever whatever gift or business you
have
you're in the arts you're in finance
whatever it is we said it earlier
here it is here's the place of
opportunity so what if that's taken away
who could live here where would you stay
up with me frankie
where would the wealth come from that
that pays for
look where we are look what we're
looking at right let's turn around and
look behind us
look at these buildings how would occupy
these buildings
only only wealthy businessmen that are
putting you to work
can afford to occupy that building
mm-hmm
but what if there was none of that
so you split but i'm saying like you
think new york can go in that direction
sure because i first met you today you
seem like a very optimistic guy
i am what's your forecast for here that
was sort of a
pessimistic so where things are going so
my optimism lies
in my nature to be a red-blooded
american
okay love our country i love the people
and all the ethnicity in our country i
love our constitution as it is
next year or two say to five years you
think it's gonna
it's got some good days ahead you think
you new york bounces back like it always
has
or you're worried more about these big
macro political issues well i think it's
global change right i think this
one world water global mentality is
going to affect
our city our city is going to seem small
and insignificant by comparison to
something like that right
but um it's my hope
to see that that notion is eliminated
and that we emerge as we were as
a country with concerns and conflicts
and things that have to be worked out
yeah and a smaller government that will
affect change that will take the city
and
find that homeless guy and find out why
he's there
and give him help get him educated get
him clean
and maybe two percent of them can be
helped we don't know
yeah i believe in both sides in that is
capitalism
but uh i don't think you should be
sitting home with your mercedes-benz
parked outside which 500
sneakers not working all day okay i
don't want to support that
but certainly you know welfare and these
food things
and even you know child support and all
these
things that are available to people you
have to know what taken advantage of as
well
yeah uh you'd be anyone would be foolish
to think that
you know that's not uh being taken
advantage of yeah but but there are
people who really
do have needs yeah and so so we should
help
those are the people that deserve help
the final words that's it one this is
this is my home this is what i'm
connected to
uh this is where my writing comes from
my art comes from my inspirations come
from right here building comes from
my project cool uh
that's it i want it the way it was until
next one thanks for coming along
hope you enjoyed that frank see you
again fist pumps
pretty well boom
done i like that frame